je trouvais un bug sur le site principal
de la croix rouge pourra que leur monde
s'il n'est pas dans les scop a testé
normalement mais je me tue par hasard
donc je veux leur dire mr qui
l'autorisent
[Musique]
là je commence à tester la croix-rouge
lantages est la croix rouge c'est qu'ils
nous fournissent le code source du site
internet
je peux regarder dedans pour pouvoir
chercher des vulnérabilités après sinon
ça sera plutôt se balader sur le site
comme initiateur classique mais en
essayant de chercher la petite bête
une fois qu'on l'a trouvé ce bug la voir
si c'est possible grâce à ce blog la
d'exploiter de pouvoir voler les
informations de d'une saute du site soit
d'un utilisateur
moi ce qui me plaît basse et déjà c'est
le fun c'est que même si je trouve c'est
une bonne façon d des entreprises le
modèle et bien c'est à dire que moi
c'est toujours des bugs suis récompensé
là au moins ça nous permet d'avoir un
cadre légal pour faire ça et
[Musique]
certains types de failles qu'on voudrait
avoir pour des raisons internes par
exemple qu'une unité locale ne voit pas
les données d'une autre unité locale par
des magouilles
maintenant ce qui est bien c'est que il
tape très large et ils vont taper toutes
les failles de auxquelles on n'aurait
pas pensé c'est ça ou c'est là où c'est
très intéressant la dernière on a déjà
participé et les chercheurs en sécurité
ont trouvé des failles qui ont amené en
fait à des gros travaux sur notre
application de sécurisation les
applications elle évolue tout le temps
en fait du coup même si on avait corrigé
toutes les failles de l'année dernière
ça se trouve y en a qu'on pas été
détectée la dernière et et puis comme on
fait des modifications pour introduire
des failles en fait donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir c'est ce programme constant de
recherche de failles c'est vraiment un
du gagnant gagnant e gagne de l'argent
nous on gagne en fiabilité
aujourd'hui on a on va avoir toutes les
entreprises du cac 40 les licornes où
les eaux une licorne comme blabla car
deezer dailymotion et on en a d'autres
et après vous allez avoir toutes les
start up les tpe/pme conte de
l'appétence au niveau numérique ont des
outils numériques a testé donc là nous
on intervient avec notre communauté vous
pouvez choisir dix vingt trente quarante
personnes ou les 15000 personnes la
communauté l'avantagé qu'ont démultiplie
les méthodologies on est testé en
continu
[Musique]
le marché est en train vraiment
d'évoluer puisque ça devient vraiment un
standard eux
en cybersécurité est quelque chose que
maintenant on sait que c'est efficace ça
fonctionne et un acteur comme yes ouïe
ac aujourd'hui à vraiment est la
capacité de mobiliser à travers le monde
puisqu'il ya nous on n'a pas de
frontières c'est numérique
[Musique]